hi guys it's greg i did its john today
the very comfortable relaxed John and
Greg are going to do a little unboxing
video my manager did not tell me that
she received the box and it was too big
to leave in my front door cuz I was gone
it's been several weeks now but here it
is um you know from WV consumer products
you guys are going to watch us and bucks
a batman be superman hero package box
the cameras higher today so if you
capture the BBS poster and i'm wearing
this shirt to make it look like i'm a
huge DC fan so here we are oh man
styrofoam can have a sword fight
hilarious that's what we do here we
bring comedy do agree the real rejects
that's a cool box that's pretty cool
that's a really cool box look you got
you go wow there's all these different
pictures of them whoa it's the wood this
makes that's the one this is the one I
like right here that's not one oh yeah
this is cool too they're about to kiss
that's what it's about that man I me
Superman this Valentine's Day oh right
cool top of it yes sweet your I Twista
thing or should I just the thing how
about we just start doing this together
okay whoa no keep in mind i keep all the
cool stuff okay whoa there's already
cool stuff on here as an honorary member
of the DC Comics superhero team Warner
Brothers consumer products is assembled
an exclusive hero pack featuring the
last collectibles from the highly
anticipated action-adventure film Batman
V Superman dawn of justice okay cool
looks like we got some awesome cards
here look at that mmm yeah that's really
good job i'm helping out with the focus
of the camera how do you know they're
gonna see it are you gonna see well hey
you can see it just as poorly from here
wow someone in okay all right all right
well this is my yeah i like that i keep
the cards cards are mine do we draw
I'm like its fourth grade liked boys
yeah no it's pretty simple the cards i
keep won't show everything don't show
everything know anything about a
surprise oh well this is an oddly
constructed box in a very cool can you
just keep it over there all right honey
oh shoot I know what I want but here
let's take a look at this thing Oh what
is it what is it grow oh it's a Superman
metals oh sweet battles diecast moo
that's really cool this makes me like
Superman Moore's eyes are blue Superman
does contain blue eyes this makes
perfect sense but it actually looks cool
this looks really it looks like a
handsome young Amit I want to look like
this Superman yeah you should I think
you should get your body built just like
that it's not about the body it's about
the face and the hair okay we'll get
plastic surgery you you too can I see
did you want this I just want us to look
I can't you on it no not if you want it
you can have it he looks kind of danny
boyle good next item please this thing
oh this thing is for an adult collector
Oh interesting okay I'm gonna see what's
in here shoot that sound I know it
sounds like when you fart oh cool that's
awesome oh oh that's really cool I don't
want to show you guys yeah this is to
have since this is like Tarantino's this
is my gold briefcase that makes me
excited all over it yeah thnkx we want
to watch the movie all over yet oh sweet
all right my toys you know John I feel
like by the end of this I'm gonna keep
old you're probably gonna keep all the
toys yeah yeah okay just letting you
know I'm gonna go back to something a
little smaller again yes I see it's a
Batman nightmare Batman I'm mmm from the
know it's a que nightmare oh that's cool
yeah I like I was night like dark night
ner who's even got a little five o'clock
shadow he does have a five o'clock show
he's gritty oh man did I feel like this
bad man could kick my ass John next toy
please alright next time please Oh
wanted to buy Legos oh man I wanted to
buy Legos this is a hobby oh my god is
the best man I was like I want to pick
up a new hobby knife feeling legos would
be a good and hey who do you love more
than Lego Batman not many people on know
how much you know sweet and there's Lex
Luthor here and there's Lois Lane Wonder
Woman and Superman dude everybody oh
right the whole team I like how Lois
Lane is like really put on a lot of
weight well everyone has that same kind
of Nelson's one everyone looks buff she
looks like she put on way
this is wearing a suit now you don't get
a play on my legs what is like this
something awesome oh this will totally
fit me hey this your incentive right
besides it oh I want to keep this shirt
but I won't fit me well they're just
working out a lot you're right could be
a goal yeah is literally gonna help out
your left look at that it's like women
in thermal shirts yeah oh dear God sure
I'm gonna Rob to go to the gym in this
is an official under armor Batman shirt
okay I gotta be look colon cleanse so I
could fit in this shirt I mean and you
know commit to a lifestyle healthy
exercise and eating right I haven't
doing that I've been doing more of that
I'm really committed today after i saw
this Jonah Hill interviews I was
watching a lot of them about him losing
weight and really inspired me so I'm
gonna be more on top of it you know so I
could fit into this shirt one day it's
gonna but hey I'm glad to hear to jump
right here we go and whoop yes hey dude
that on that was almost cool oh I saw
Tyrone rocking I now I know what Tyrone
got it out you see what I Rome looks
good with like short hair and a hat like
I need like my curls and stuff I look
goofy no you don't yeah I just need it
you just need to learn how it fits you
it's a hat I no no no no no I need me
the way a hat fits you'd be surprised
they're different ways to wear hats in
different kinds we're just gonna give
the head a try I look like I'm trying to
fit in if you feel like the time it just
doesn't look like a school without the
heck you know John if you're not gonna
agree with me just keep your mouth shut
that simple jeez Oh what is this now
something new Oh John likes to start
with the big items first I didn't know
that was in there cuz everything was so
big that I couldn't see like no glue or
solar needed but the whole point was
this supposed to be metal earth 3d metal
model kits y yeah those are getting
popular now what are these little metal
model like all you have in there is all
the different little strips of metal
that
make up the parts and you kind of build
your little 3d yeah it's kinda like a 3d
puzzle but but more intricate and more
impressive oh that sounds like so much
fun yeah we way to focus your mind
Warner Brothers you guys give the best
unboxing this is a pretty sick bugs a
crazy box they happen what is this ooh
another shirt that will hopefully fit me
um I don't want to reveal the actual
size I am Telling size of the shirt oh
no no no it's not I mean you're a medium
yeah otherwise I give it to you anyone
sure I feel like I'd look good in the
Wonder Woman t-shirt it's up to you nuh
and I was kind of like hey it's funny
but you know Greg can kind of get away
with wearing a wonderful teacher you
know yeah do you think do you want it
I'm willing to give I want it cuz i
would actually wear cuz i would be like
yes like what if you want it it's like I
know more about wonder woman hey or to
you I just like what wonder one
represents I really like the shirt
though okay how bad you want there are
other shirts in this box how bad you are
there yes fun the whole budget sure so
won't fit me let's do this okay oh come
on Warner Brothers send me the right
size why are you doing this to notice is
good this is good this is good for you
oh my god I know these are be the
perfect new church to wear right now I
know it's this is the first day of the
rest of your life Oh God life is
changing that is so cool Royals unboxing
video oh okay yeah betsson next one boo
Boop something else can you get a pin no
a toy no shirt no pants just in
something I'm sure but who's on it it is
a shirt the s for Superman yeah Superman
dude they have they have Alfred on sign
with everything you need and I like that
they knew that if you're going to
cadee you would want to be back I wonder
if that meant where is one of those
workout shirts that a stewardess
buffness Superman like just came buff
yeah I always wondered that like other
are there like I was like really skinny
growing up but then he just be chained
but they're just like normal like
average looking people on Krypton yeah
there's like people who are like an
average weight or as everyone just kind
of belief Kryptonian weight loss just go
to her for a while eventually your body
will just go to she can't muscles need
to be so much easier here you ready for
the last one I'm ready all right here
last one yeah oh it's pretty sacred ok
close your eyes hold out your hands
there you go look at that
oh cool it's like my Wonder Woman Barbie
it is a wonder woman Barbie it's like an
actual Wonder Woman doll it's wicked d
this is like the one Barbie doll i would
actually keep yeah i'll take no John I
want it I have a toy collection okay do
you want to keep them okay the empty box
yes you keep the box you keep the box
that's a cool bar is it gonna boxing I
kind of don't want to let you keep the
bug you can have the box yeah can I have
the phone need the box I have enough box
this is yeah I'd like to keep the bug
okay thanks you have a problem I'm sorry
you didn't get anything in this video
okay don't worry about it i'll go buy
one I really thought I give away
something blue they're all pretty cool
yeah this is autism actually they're all
these are all pretty wicked I'm jealous
of me I did mention this earlier but
just to be safe this is a disclaimer
that the products I've received for
Warner Brothers consumer products and
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice is for
content creation purposes what's so
natural do some crazy natural the way
that is so natural alright guys well boy
they really got the merge down this year
yeah man the merch is wicked them this
is really good stuff listen guys if
you're new to this channel please
subscribe today so maybe one day I'll
give away one of these toys as a little
contest Newman typical nah I'm gonna
keep them you're gonna keep it I'm gonna
keep them off like a gift card AMC or
something John has videos on this
channel every episode he's in goes on
this play that's called reasons to Jerry
and he also has dank ass Stubbs podcast
with the podcast from Dane cast steps of
a man what does a beautiful voice oh say
John only sometimes where does Beauty
come from the eye of the beholder and
you know many years of socio cultural
construct i believe the correct answer
is the beauty killed the Beast yeah
no no cuz where's the beauty comfort the
chicken ya knows the air it's probably
chicken